vientos que atacan a nuestros oficiales
de policías
legislación al apoyo para autorizar
fondos para apoyar a primeras personas
de la línea del 9/11 y sus familias
policiales han jurado bueno a ir al
peligro cuando todo el mundo huye lo
hacen con deseo para proteger a nuestras
familias ya nuestras comunidades
estoy orgulloso que la mayoría de los
oficiales policiales son los mejores de
los mejores y arriesgan sus vidas sin
dudarlo los policías saben que nos
apoyamos desafortunadamente creo que los
resultados cuando no se dan como en
portland minneapolis chicago y nueva
york
hacen
a decisión consciente de no apoyar a los
oficiales asesinatos tiroteos
la violencia y la sangre derramada que
se ven en estas ciudades no está
ayudando ahora es una suerte es un
resultado para mí de no permitir que los
oficiales protejan a nuestras
comunidades
como senador kamala harris fue un apoyo
restringir a la policía contraste cortar
su entrenamiento
y hacer que nuestras comunidades y
vecindarios sean más peligrosos que ya
son de lo que ya lo son el presidente
trump apoya la creación
un lugar de entrenamiento nacional para
desde escalar y comunicar para darle a
los oficiales más herramientas para
resolver conflictos sin violencia
la diferencia entre trump pensó y bailén
jarvis es clara con sus opciones
la más propicia les o las más anti
radicales
valoramos la seguridad de nuestros
familiares para unirse a los miembros de
la asociación de organizaciones
policiales y apoyar la reelección del
presidente de donald trump gracias
y dios bendiga a estados unidos
[Música]